[Music]
skin lightening is about power
it's an expression of power and so
people who lighten their skin are doing
this because they are responding to
a power dynamic that exists in their
particular society
in many parts of the world lighter skin
is considered to be more beautiful than
darker skin
a beauty standard that's been around for
hundreds of years
lighter skin has been associated with
power and privilege and the beauty
industry has been profiting
selling skin lightening creams and soaps
which are popular across asia africa and
the caribbean
by 2027 the global market for skin
lighteners is estimated to reach over 12
billion dollars
skin whitening is definitely a huge
business
the patients look forward to have a much
fairer or a whiter skin and they could
go to any length to achieve that
[Music]
[Music]
the history
of skin lightening here in the united
states it actually begins with white
women white women here would use skin
lightening products because they were
trying to emulate
beauty standards and beauty practices
that were circulating in europe
and then around the jim crow era what we
see is skin lightening products
being used and sold and circulated
within the african-american community
black women would use this partly
because
it would be
a survival strategy essentially
the lighter your skin was the more
access to resources you would have and
so
this is what
made skin lightening products in part
popular
among more communities of color
the idea was that if you were trying to
emulate the people in power
you were seen as more civilized you were
seen as cleaner
and therefore that would give you access
to certain things it would allow you
upward mobility upward class mobility
etc
when i was a kid i could say i was one
shade
more darker than my sister
and we both went to the same school
everybody used to be a little surprised
when
i told them she was my sister so they
said how is there such a huge difference
in your skin color
so i always had this but there was no
pressure from my family members
but friends and classmates definitely
did question me about my skin color once
upon a time
in asia the practice of skin whitening
is related to colorism a looks-based
discrimination that occurs within racial
or ethnic groups
and in india a part of everyday life
individuals who have
fairer skin are more acceptable
when it comes to career or marriage
if you also go to the matrimonial
columns in the newspapers or magazines
they say i look for a fairer bride or
there are
women who look for a fairer groom so
it's equal
desire to have a fairer skin is deep
seated in indian population
most experts agree that colorism bled
into india's caste system where darker
skin has since become associated with
indians at the lowest levels of the
social hierarchy who do manual labor
historians are undecided about the
origins of this colour prejudice
while some point to ancient migrations
by indo-europeans arabs and persians all
of whom had strikingly lighter coloured
skin than local inhabitants
others note the more recent colonial
rule of the british empire
the britishers ruled us for about
roughly 200 years the indians were kind
of treated
very badly or they were slaves they
worked for the britishers for many many
years so they look forward to the
british skin and they thought that the
british skin was acceptable because they
were fairer asia is the biggest market
for skin lightening products the world
health organization found that 40 of
women they asked in china india and
other asian countries said they
regularly use them
in india skin lightening is a
multi-million dollar industry around 80
of skin moisturizers on the market are
for skin whitening
the most widely used was fair and lovely
it earns more than 500 million dollars
each year for unilever from india alone
so i used to see the product fair and
lovely even while i was a kid so it's
about
45 years old
it is quite popular and it's
manufactured by a company called
hindustan unilever limited and
it's a booming business
due to global public pressure on brands
following the 2020 george floyd protests
the indian affiliate of unilever changed
the name to glow and lovely
in a statement the company said we
recognize the use of words fair white
and light suggests a singular ideal of
beauty that we don't think is right and
we want to address this
the indian government has proposed jail
terms and fines for advertisements which
promote skin whitening
but that hasn't stopped many indians
obsessed with lighter skin buying and
using these products
you know something like this has been
going on in our societies for so long
we discriminate people based on their
skin colon and no one's saying anything
about it you know when you see the way
it affects children it affects women it
affects men
and they grow with that sense of
insecurity
it's like a journey we've been on this
toxic belief you know where it started
with culture it started with social
hierarchies and the media keeps
endorsing it
companies they may not have initiated it
but by endorsing it by selling products
through advertisements that say that you
know you can be whiter in seven days or
or white is better if you're fairer
you'll be more successful too the thing
is they're using the insecurity that
colorism has bred to sell their product
so you're kind of making money off of
people's insecurities
and then you know we just lived with it
and it's become normal
apart from using whitening products some
people go even further receiving
cosmetic procedures like chemical peels
or laser treatment
in recent years an antioxidant called
glutathione is gaining popularity
while it's available to take orally many
consumers believe injecting the drug is
faster and more effective for skin
whitening but this hasn't been
scientifically proven
if they have a medical condition
yes i would do it but if they just want
to achieve a skin whitening
you know treatment i would refuse to do
that for them
because uh the safety and efficacy of
the drug
glutathione is not well established
glutathione is produced naturally in the
human liver in india oral glutathione is
approved for treating skin conditions
and for skin whitening but intravenous
or intramuscular glutathione is only
approved to treat medical conditions
like the side effects of chemotherapy
there are very few clinical trials there
are certain drawbacks to those studies
because uh those studies were done on a
very limited number of subjects also the
patients were not followed up for a long
term or a long period
there are practitioners who do use it
but it's an off label indication
but what has been observed is that
it's a very subjective opinion from the
patient in terms of
how much of a skin
lightening they have been able to
achieve with the treatment so it's not
necessary that if you administer the
infusion in 10 patients all of the 10
patients are going to observe the same
change
due to a lack of research and
regulations clinics make up their own
protocols and set their own prices
ranging from 50 to 70 dollars per
injection
in the philippines almost 400 years of
spanish and then american colonial rule
helped to reinforce a notion of beauty
as white and so today glutathione is
becoming a popular alternative to
traditional lightning products
when we look at a place like the
philippines
people there will use skin lightening
products because they're trying to
emulate
those who are in power they're trying to
emulate things that they see on tv
and when you watch for example
philippine tv it's inundated with actors
and actresses and performers who
are typically light-skinned when you
look at the philippine government many
politicians are either mixed race or
light skinned
based on my experience
owns a beauty salon in downtown manila
which offers beauty services including
glutathione drips for skin whitening
some of my
my interviews
lighter young skin nila so talaganga
the country's food and drug
administration has warned against the
use of injectable glutathione for skin
whitening flagging its toxic effects on
the liver kidneys and nervous system
but many big medical groups and small
beauty salons still provide it with a
price tag of up to 120 dollars per
session
[Music]
some beauty salons or moonlighting
nurses even offer injections at home
but glutathione drips can also be bought
easily online so some take it into their
own hands following online tutorials
so for tonight's video i'm gonna show
you how to inject yourself with
glutathione mm-hmm
i would say that is unacceptable because
sometimes if it is injected in the wrong
manner or if it is injected in a huge
dose it can cause to severe allergic
reactions sometimes it there can be a
casualty or an emergency
these videos should be
totally prohibited on social media
platforms
i think it's an issue of access the more
available
a certain process is the more people are
going to be curious about it
these more advanced
processes what they do is they create
more legitimacy for the practice
but at no point do we step back and say
well why is this necessary to begin with
while some are still doing whatever it
takes to become lighter others are
beginning to embrace their own skin and
awareness of color discrimination has
increased in recent years
in india advocacy group darkest
beautiful has been organizing workshops
and events to fight colorism what needs
to happen is change both within culture
as well as change from you know these
external endorsements and and cosmetic
brands and businesses have a
responsibility you know it's not about
people want it and so we do it
this is not like some a problem that we
can fix overnight it takes several such
movements several such campaigns like
cars like the darkest beautiful campaign
and so it's going to take some time
before we can
feel the change
we have to ground change in structures
so we need to see major reforms in
education we need to see major reforms
in government and we need to see major
reforms in media representation and not
just aesthetic representation it's not
enough to cast
darker-skinned people on tv and think
yay people are going to love their skin
it's about how we're represented in
government
and taking away
historical governmental policies that
were
created to subjugate people of color
that were created to subjugate darker
skin people
we spend a lot of time grooming our
outside right we
dress up we want to be presentable we
dress a certain way
so i think what really
will help us is a mental grooming to
keep telling ourselves every day that
you are enough you are enough just the
way you are and every skin color is
beautiful
on the next episode of business of
beauty
istanbul is arguably the world's most
popular city to get hair transplant
treatment
before covid hit it's estimated that
half a million people came here every
year in the hopes of regaining their
hair
in no small part because of the quality
of the work being offered and the price
it's offered at
but it's a lightly regulated industry
and with hundreds of clinics competing
against each other the pressure is on to
increase operations and cut prices even
further
[Music]
you